okay so one of the things that concerns
me about modern Christianity is that the
tradition being founded over 2,000 years
ago fails to mention certain things that
I think are now important seems to me
that the atom bomb safe and wildly
available contraception interplanetary
rocketry and the computer and the
accompanying specter of strong AI are
the fundamental game changers
I think these merit a place in our
symbolic cosmology yet religion in
general has failed to integrate them and
popular culture has filled the gap often
with symbols that are hostile to
religion I think that this is a
fundamental assault on the foundation of
religion what kind of path forward do
you see regarding this issue okay so
okay so I would say that first thing I
would say is that I don't think that
it's true that those things are missing
from the Christian tradition I think
they are indeed there in the Christian
tradition I just think that people don't
know how to look for them don't can't
recognize them when they see them now of
course not the specifics not an atom
bomb or you know not not specifics in
the sense of ovum of the actual
technology like a cell phone no the you
know the the the the Bible does not or
the Christianity does not talk about the
cell phone but I have been advocating
for a while now to read for people to
rediscover the the traditions that come
out of Enoch that come out of the Book
of Enoch no there are some things in the
Book of Enoch which are which have been
rejected by the fathers which which are
not I would say are not compatible with
Christianity today but I think that
there are some things in those
traditions that are extremely important
to understand now the the Book of Enoch
tells the story of the fall basically
that image that I told you about how
there's the fall and then there's a a
process of
X accelerating fall which leads all the
way to the flood okay now this process
of accelerated fall is characterized by
different things it is characterized by
a mixture between the humans and the
angels and so Angels have children with
the human females and they it creates
monsters and these fallen angels are
demons and so these demons have
offspring and these offspring are these
giants these monsters and the demons
also teach the human beings how to
modify nature okay and that includes
technology and that includes magic and
it also includes funny things like
teaching women to wear makeup and and
and necromancy all of those all of those
all those those really fun things so I
think it says even women how to paint
their nails in some of the versions like
it teaches women how to paint their
nails and so this idea of how a fall is
a is a modification of nature and that
this modification of nature leads to
several things it leads to weapons of
destruction you see it in two volcana it
leads to massive weapons which become
more and more destructive it also leads
to it leads to a form of - a form of
sexual debauchery which is also there in
the story of this fall and it also leads
to a form of it you could see
leading to a form of infertility as well
okay the the some of the traditions talk
about how the the Giants created hybrids
and created all these these these
chimera these monsters by mixing
different animals together and creating
all these different these different
types of monsters you know and you can
see that happening right now I mean we
can see that that there is a lack of
metaphysical reason why we are doing
certain things and because of that
there's all these crazy activities which
are happening the consequences of which
no one knows what they are because
they're not doing it out of out of an
attachment to logos they're not doing it
out of an attachment to something higher
but they've attached themselves to all
these demons all these little
principalities all these little
knowledge --is and and it's like they
dive into these deliberately little
knowledge --is and now they're creating
different technologies that are going in
different directions and they they're
incapable of seeing the big picture
incapable of understanding how how for
example they were incapable of
understanding what contraception would
do to the world what it would do to
relationships what it would do to
society would would do to civilization
they just incapable of understanding
that but but because a demon because a
demon possessed the demon of sex the
demon of desire the deme of pleasure all
that that became the prime focus then we
jump in and we act based on that and we
don't and we sweet we stop seeing the
big picture and it's the same for
something like these crazy technologies
like the atom bomb or artificial
intelligence you know I always tell
people if you want to understand you
know this the story of the Book of Enoch
and this notion of of a of a demon or a
manifestation of a demon or the
manifestation of a fall
angel and and a kind of of a kind of
monstrous body it's like that comes
that's pretty close to what artificial
intelligence could be it doesn't mean
it's only going to be that and it
doesn't mean that out of that isn't
going to come the solution because in
the story of Genesis there's also a hint
as to how all of this can then be
flipped out of the fall and so Noah in
many traditions is said to be married to
nama who is the the sister of tubal-cain
and so she nama is a descendant of of
cain and so this tradition that talks
about how noah married nama is there to
show how even though mixture in the
whole process
this mixture between the different
people and the the mixture between the
people and and the the principalities is
what's creating all these monsters that
Noah it's by marrying a daughter of Cain
and also by being a technical person by
building an ark that's how he's able to
then preserve the whole thing and so but
then so there is it does so the
tradition does actually talk about
everything that's happening today it's
it's been talked about in in in our
tradition it's just we just need to be
to know how to look for it and also to
be able to to to let's say understand it
and so the the image like I told you
this image of the New Jerusalem for
example is this image of how even our
technologies even or you know even our
kind of technical understanding could be
transformed and could participate in
this massive it's a this filling up of
the world with meaning but it's not
going to happen if we are attached only
to the demons if we're only attached to
the principalities and if we're only
following ma'am and if we're only
interested in money for all
following our desire to have an easier
life or our desire to to you know to
have this or that power on these are
these are those people and so you know
until until there is a awakening and
people come together and see the big
picture then I then I'm sad to say that
I think that our that our technologies
although they they they they can be
helpful that they're they're the ones
who are going to also bring us into into
into darkness you could say so so yeah
so I hope that's helpful you know and
we're seeing it right now we're seeing
it happen right now you know I'm
probably going to do a video on this
very soon and talk about this whole
system like the problem of we're seeing
it with patreon and we're seeing it with
with these D platforming of how and and
also that the credit card companies and
the banking system that are becoming
ideologically possessed that is very
frightening so we have all these systems
of financial control and all these
systems of financial transactions and
and we've kind of given our so we've
given our our autonomy to these systems
that are that are kind of techno
bureaucratic systems but once they
become possessed by a demon then we're
we're in serious trouble like we are in
serious trouble if that happened then it
does kind of seem to be happening at the
time and david Flores says the mark of
the beast and yes it does indeed have to
do with the mark of the beast so I'll
probably will I'm hoping to do a video
on that because the mark of the beast
and and also 666 it's a it's a it's a
very important it's a it's a very
important aspect of symbolism that I
think would be helpful for people to to
understand today instead of you know
just attributing it randomly like we we
often see you know oh people their
intuition is right sometimes like their
intuition about what that
talking about is is right but people
tend to to be too too narrow in in what
it would it refers to it and what
pattern is participating in so so
probably you might see a video on on 666
the mark the Beast
pretty soon I'm hesitating to do it just
because it would it look like you see
the title you know the symbolism of 666